oh geez you need to sell these how'd you
pronounce that soup guard Apple a lot of
people must point to what they want to
order right or just pick up the last
line how do you pronounce that Corning's
burger clots Wow
but how long's this man you've been
running like this since the beginning Oh
13 years ago stop seriously yes let's
start off with good for the stops let's
do the beer batter the sauerkraut yeah
let's go for that and throw the
vegetarian mushroom ravioli in as well
wonderful
okay great so I'll keep all of the menu
for now okay thank you sear it in first
whoa yeah almost lost it
regroup regroup where is Missy I'll
bring it right out mr. Ramsey's first
red pepper beurre blanc yes sir
our seared diver scallops with a red
pepper beurre blanc Wow thank you
and scallops and only round right yes
they are we have beautiful sea scallops
I'm not sure why they cut it up today no
my oh well thank you very much it's like
the dog stood the I mean seriously
that's rancid Oh I said would that work
it's good like me give me any comments
back to show comments yeah oh [ __ ]
thank you that terrible well have Val
take care of it for you who's Val me I
like the way you talk about yourself in
the third person seared diver scallops
tastes like [ __ ] yes like [ __ ] really
Wow okay any specific kind of [ __ ] for
this no
these here are the sauerkraut in bhakti
none of these are edible flowers or not
they are chrysanthemums yeah okay great
thank you all right hmm they aren't
terrible having food is so data's
extraordinary like a pair of commas
bollocks
this I have here is the mushroom
graciously Terran cream well there she
is
Wow Wow
yes delicious I mean you're kidding me
no no I'm [ __ ] delicious seriously
really good another flowers I'm all
about ah you had me going there for the
whole second I thought it was all about
the food I may be next course darling
the flowers are absolutely delicious the
flowers and this menu doesn't change
every decade it's the same menus been on
for 13 years Jonathan doesn't check oh
sorry I asked you a question always
answer doesn't change I'm sorry you you
answer
Melissa's question first and I'll go
back to me listen you said this doesn't
change but once a decade and I said
Jonathan doesn't change my right um
you've been here a long time you've seen
the place in decline and what's the big
issues there what a disorganization
things unclear yeah nothing consistent
yeah and you know one puts the other on
edge and we get the brunt end of it
Lisa's listening to every word you're
saying
I can barely hear you no no it's just
talking to mr. okay I'm sorry do
whatever you need to do um what's the
worst thing he's ever done to you
he smacked me on the back of the head
and in front of the customers
seriously in front because not hard but
still uh demeaning yeah I'll say damn